et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
damien abad bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous député de
l'ain président du groupe l'est
républicain à l'assemblée nationale on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
julien lécuyer de la voix du nord
bonjour julien bonjour oriane bonjour
monsieur gbagbo jours on commence
évidemment par la crise sanitaire et
cette actualité cet après midi à
l'assemblée nationale un débat est
organisé entre le gouvernement les
députés débattent sur la gestion de
cette crise sanitaire quel va être le
message des républicains au gouvernement
c'est plus de vaccins - de baratin je
pense que le message il est clair il
faut qu'aujourd'hui on vaccine davantage
et qu'on sorte de cette ambiance
permanente a parlé à parlementer à
discours et non je crois que voilà apte
et au delà de ça honnêtement ce débat à
l'assemblée nationale il a peu d'utilité
peu d'intérêt c'est un débat qui se fait
dans le cas de la semaine de contrôle
c'est pas ça qu'on veut salir vos
dialogues qu'instaure de bien sûr mais
tellement début on a un faux dialogue
depuis le début' on a pas de
concertation et on a pas de dialogue
avec nous avant la réalité c'est quoi la
réalité c'est qu'on a simplement des
pseudo-débats nous ce que l'on veut
c'est un suivi régulier de la gestion de
la crise sanitaire
un suivi régulier des débats réguliers
des échanges permanents
tout nous a été refusé la commission
denquête n'a pas pu se prolonger des
débats dans l'hémicycle de demander au
nom d'artiste 1-1 n'a pas pu se être
fait un bilan de la vaccination non plus
la réalité voilà c'est que là on a un
pseudo débat qui vise uniquement à
colmater les brèches mais qui est sans
grand intérêt
vous avez été convaincu par le discours
du président il hier qu'en déplacement à
valenciennes appelant à une à une course
de vitesse a poussé la
d'accélérateur on est en capacité de le
faire
malheureusement on a pris beaucoup de
retard
il faut effectivement appuyé sur la
d'accélérateur
il faut vacciner matin midi et soir mais
que c'est tardif que c'est lent et
pourquoi une reconversion aussi tardive
la vaccination c'est la seule porte de
sortie pour retrouver une vie normale et
donc pour cela il faut vraiment mettre
les bouchées doubles donc ça veut dire
avoir des deux ça veut dire arrêtez avec
ces déclarations contradictoires comme
on a connu sur l'estrade n'est qu'avec
ce psychodrame sur la suspension 72
heures avant l'avis de l'agencé
européenne du médicament et 24 heures
avant la mi de l'eau msc un psychodrame
pour vous il l'aurait pas fait non il
fallait pas suspendre pour une raison
très simple c'est que il
un avis qui était rendu 24 heures après
si on a vu un avis plus tard dix jours
après j'aurais compris cette décision de
suspension au nom du principe de
précaution
mais là on a créé de la confusion et
vous savez ce qui se passe sur le
terrain c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya un
rendez vous sur deux qui est déprogrammé
à l'astra zeneca parce qu'il ya des gens
ne veulent plus se faire vacciner parce
que la confiance est rompue
maintenant il faut rétablir cette
confiance donc oui il nous faut vacciner
davantage moi j'ai noté les
vaccinodromes je me souvenir dumisa
santé qui nous y menons fera pas
vacciner de rome et aujourd'hui on voit
bien qu'on a perdu finalement des
semaines et des semaines et on va en
faire un maintenant on nous dit on va
faire les plus 70 ans
mais nous ce que nous demandons c'est la
vaccination de masse c'est pas la
vaccination par tranche d'âge
c'est la vaccination de masse au monde
distinction si on veut arriver aux 30
millions de personnes vaccinées
comme l'annoncé brillant à un public au
mois de juin il faut effectivement
vacciner le plus grand nombre toutes
celles et tous ceux en tout cas qui le
souhaitent on a dit un peu
d'organisation
on l'a fait déjà on a fait les ehpad on
a tous n'est pas protégé parmi les gens
qui les ennuis mais égalité ou sur les
personnes âgées il faut encore continuer
bien entendu avec une priorisation il ya
les plus 75 ans il faut aussi faire bien
entendu l'écomobilité il faut d'abord
finir ses priorités mais aujourd'hui la
logique des choses c'est qu'on devrait
aussi pouvoir engager la démarche de la
vaccination de masse est ce que je
constate en fait c'est quoi c'est que
finalement on essaye de gagner du temps
on nous dit on va faire les 60 début 70
ans
et demain on va faire les plus 65 ans et
puis après les plus de 60 ans oui et à
chaque fois on a une semaine après
semaine les enseignants
alors si on commence à rentrer par
catégorie socioprofessionnelle
je suis très inquiet de l'usiné à gaz
que l'on est en train de créer non là
qu'il fallait pas prioriser les
enseignants pour vous c'est pas que
c'est parce que je suis en train de vous
dire je vous dis simplement que la
préméditation affaires pas que la
priorisation des enseignants oui parce
que la priorisation des enseignants
qu'est-ce qu'elle entraînait il ya
d'autres professions qu'ils ont à dire
mais aussi les caissiers il va y avoir
d'autres propositions qui sont en
contact direct
non la réalité c'est quoi c'est qu'on a
un virus malheureusement qui circule
activement
on a une accélération de ce virus
malheureusement avec notamment le
variant britannique
c'est que moi je suis inquiet parce que
là où le gouvernement raison paris par
contre c'est qu'il faut maintenir nos
écoles ouverte le plus longtemps
possible
c'est essentiel mais on voit bien qu'on
a une recrudescence de l'épidémie et que
c'est que ce truc russe en épidémie elle
exige de nous deux choses la
responsabilité dans nos actes quotidiens
c'est à dire le respect des gestes
barrières
c'est à dire aussi mais pas cette
infantilisation permanente moi j'ai pas
envie que le premi
soit le surveillant général d'un
pensionnaire pour enfants la réalité
aujourd'hui c'est quoi c'est qu'il nous
faut au contraire responsabiliser les
gens et de l'autre côté il nous faut
vacciner responsabiliser ou obligé est
ce que par exemple il faudrait hareng
comment dire consolider les restrictions
et par exemple leur dire clairement aux
français et à imposer le fait de ne pas
accueillir des gens chez soi on sait que
c'est une recommandation ce qu'il faut
obliger c'est impossible on peut pas
obliger les gens ont peut pas aller dans
le domicile des personnes non et c'est
la responsabilité
mais quand je vois ce qui s'est passé à
marseille avec le carnaval certains qui
dans la rue ça au fût ce que tout le
monde parce que le problème c'est
toujours pareil c'est que vous avez ceux
qui respectent et finalement la société
française aujourd'hui elle repose sur
celles et ceux qui respectent ces
consignes qui se contraignent un certain
nombre de choses et malheureusement il
n'a qui profitent de la situation
et ça c'est pas acceptable donc plutôt à
marseille vous comprenez la connaître la
colère de la ville bien entendu mais
sauf que j'ai noté aussi qui avait quand
même quelques élus du printemps
marseillais qui étaient présents dans
cette manifestation donc là aussi il
faut un peu de cohérence et éviter les
contradictions non mais ce que je dis
simplement c'est de la responsabilité
pour tous c'est aussi la vaccination
parce qu'il faut donner un objectif une
perspective parce qu'aujourd'hui on nous
parle
le confinement de couvre-feu de mesures
de freinage mais l'enjeu pour la pole et
pour nous c'est aujourd'hui de donner
une perspective aux français parce que
là ils sont déboussolés ils sont perdus
ils ont le sentiment qu'on n'y arrive
pas eh bien je pense qu'aujourd'hui il
faut réagir et donner cette perspective
avec la vaccination et avec aussi la
responsable côté des perspectives de
réouverture dans tous les lieux
mais la perspective côté vaccination le
gouvernement l'a donné un 10 millions mi
avril 20 millions en mai 30 millions en
juin c'est des perspectives il faut
qu'elle soit suivie il a donné un peu
hier c'est vrai mais aujourd'hui force
est de constater que aujourd'hui sur le
terrain au moment où je vous parle la
situation n'est pas satisfaisante
pourquoi n'est pas satisfaisante parce
que nous avons une vaccination qui est
très chaotique
nous avons des déprogrammations je vous
le dis on jette des deux on jette des
deux on a on perdait 2 on perd des doses
parce que par contre il faudra faire
plusieurs choses d'abord parce que
parfois il ya des consignes
contradictoires données au médecin ou à
celles et ceux qui vaccinent notamment
sur laquelle la captation de cette 7e
dose la question des seringues et puis
parce que malheureusement
eh bien il ya des moments où on est
obligé de vacciner comme vous le savez
dans un temps limité pour que garder
l'efficacité de ce vaccin et on ne le
fait pas et donc il ya des doses qui
sont jetés c'est la réalité dans des
départements dans les territoires
aujourd'hui et donc on peut pas accepter
alors qu'on est en pénurie de doses de
vaccins d'avoir ce gâchis là aujourd'hui
donc non on n'y est pas le compte n'y
est pas on n'y est pas on est en retard
est ce qu'on peut faire pour éviter ça
c'est quoi c'est la faute à la
bureaucratie trop d'administration jeudi
à plusieurs choses bien sûr qu'il ya eu
la bureaucratie à une technocratisation
absolue des décisions kafkaïenne qui ont
créé des troubles entre les pharmaciens
les médecins s'est par exemple la
décision aujourd'hui de recours aux
vaccinodromes mais pas hier
mais surtout et d'abord la première
chose c'est d'abord le des doses de
vaccin c'est d'abord des commandes de
biens qui arrive c'est ça qui est aussi
son vis-à-vis d'astrazeneca
parce qu'on est on a été suffisamment
loin dans justement dans le discours oui
je pense qu'il faut hausser le ton je
pense aussi que certainement il fallait
je trouve que l'idée de commander
ensemble n'est pas une mauvaise idée que
les pays européens se disent on commande
un sens mais à une condition c'est pour
être plus fort sur le marché mondial moi
il ya une chose qui m'échappe
c'est que le marché européen c'est le
premier marché mondial quand tous les
pays européens décident de commander
ensemble comment se fait-il qu ensuite
on est la dernière roue du carrosse dans
les livraisons de commandes
là il ya un problème et c'est ça qu'il
faut résoudre aujourd'hui on peut pas
être le premier marché mondial et les
derniers sérieux mais c'est à dire que
maintenant il faut passer autre il faut
que la france commande tout seul c'est
trop tard le problème c'est que même si
vous commandez tout seul la réalité
c'est que le temps que les choses ça
chemine et arrive bien sûr que
certainement à côté la commande
européenne il fallait peut-être
envisager aussi des commandes nationales
et puis des productions aussi propre de
vaccins il faut vraiment voilà il faut
il faut mettre les bouchées doubles
accéléré parce que moi ce qui m'inquiète
aujourd'hui c'est que le virus avance
plus vite que la vaccination et on le
voit parce que nos animations sur un
nouveau saturé parce que nous avons des
inquiétudes y compris d'ailleurs dans
nos écoles et que donc et notamment en
ile-de-france et dans autres france et
ailleurs est donc aujourd'hui il faut
que la vaccination rattrape le virus
ça vous semble inéluctable
le confinement d'autres territoires on
est votre question des grands tests on
évoque louis est tout à fait dans ma
région alors pas dans mon département de
l'ain mais plutôt dans le département du
rhône où d'autres départements qui sont
à côté on voit bien que de façon à une
circulation active du virus et que
personne n'y échappe
la vérité c'est que moi je suis je
défends la territorialisation parce que
la territorialisation c'est ce qui
permet quand même d'appréhender jeu m'a
dit de mal et ça c'est un grand sens la
territorialisation quand par exemple
à bientôt dans la moitié de la
population sera confiné dans sa touche
tout le monde non ça fait dix ans la
théorisation les intéressantes quand
vous avez par exemple un cluster comme
on a eu à dunkerque
quand vous êtes sur une ville précise
quand vous êtes sur un département
précis mais une fois qu ensuite se
propage malheureusement partout là il
faut des règles nationales
donc là il faut pas ses oreilles
national des marins pour vous non c'est
il faut il faut qu'on avait la liste des
départs tous que je sais elle est très
importante et elle va malheureusement
encore grandir et croître
on est dans une je trouve une vitesse
assez rapide et donc certainement qu'il
ya de nouvelles mesures qui vont être
prises
on va parler d'eux du coup de cette
crise sanitaire notamment de la dette tu
viens wii qui risque d'être un thème
majeur de la présidentielle la dette
qu'ovide ça se rembourse parce que chez
les républicains ou certains comme en
rien pas de radier ou françois baroin
plat et plaide pour créer une dette
perpétuelle dans les mains de la banque
centrale européenne et on sent que la
question elle divise clairement au sein
des républicains moi je vais vous donner
ma position très clairement une dette
sens rembourse
et quand on est de droite on a toujours
vigilants face à la dette parce que la
réalité c'est que la dette d'aujourd'hui
ce sont les impôts de demain et les
destructions d'emplois d'après demain et
que donc une dette ça se rembourse bien
sûr qu'il ya une dette qu'ovide
particulière bien sûr qu'on pourra pas
les rembourser un jour où en un an et
qu'il faut la rembourser sur le temps
avec des taux d'intérêt bas et qu'il
faut aussi que ce remboursement de la
dette soit utile notamment les
distinguer les dépenses d'investissement
des dépenses de fonctionnement mais il
faut pas se tromper les français
la réalité c'est que une dette qui ne se
rembourse pas c'est un fardeau qui pèse
sur les générations actuelles et futures
vous savez j'ai été président de
département
moi même j'ai dû sortir des emprunts
toxiques qui avait dans mon département
et on l'a fait et aujourd'hui c'est
parce qu'on l'a fait qu'on n'a pas
augmenté les impôts et qu'on a même
augmenté les dépenses d'investissement
donc voila mais là où il ya un
changement et qu'il faut que tout le
monde accepte c'est que l'adq au vide
n'est pas tout
la même que notre dette parce que elle a
un impact fort immédiat et que donc le
remboursement sera forcément non parce
que sinon on en sort on va sera trop les
dépenses publiques et après on nous dira
avait regardé vous avez donc d'isoler
cette dette qu'ovide pour la placer en
donnait là cantonné à l'avion de ligne
qui s'est par la même chose louis ont
fait l'isoler ou la volée cantonné mais
simplement mais ça change pas le fond du
problème
la réalité c'est la question du
remboursement et la remboursement c'est
la crédibilité des marchés financiers
c'est la crédibilité de l'économie
française c'est la cause la crédibilité
des entreprises françaises donc on
l'isolent ou pas de toute façon il faut
au moins qu'on se mette d'accord sur un
point c'est qu'il faut rembourser cette
dette que la france il avait soumise par
exemple qui dit on remboursera pas il ya
pas besoin ce sont des réserves il
responsable bien entendu mais surtout
qu'en plus c'est interdit par les
traités européens ils le savent très
bien
et la réalité c'est que c'est totalement
irresponsable c'est totalement
incantatoire et il y aura des lendemains
qui déchantent
on va passer au reste de l'actualité
maintenant damien abad et l'actualité ce
notamment à strasbourg puisque gérald
darmanin accuse la mairie strasbourg de
financer une mosquée soutenu par une
fédération qui défend l'islam politique
et qui a refusé de signer la charte des
principes de l'islam alors il doit y
avoir un nouveau vote de la mairie de
strasbourg la maire de strasbourg veut
posé des conditions dont la signature de
cette charte mais gérald darmanin il a
demandé à la préfète de région de saisir
la justice administrative de cette
délibération est ce qu il a eu raison
ou est ce que c'est de la politique non
moi je soutiens les intérieurs et la
raison lorsque face à l'islamisme
radical on ne peut pas avoir deux
discours il ne peut pas être dans la
contradiction permanente et je pense que
ce n'est pas à l'argent public de
financer des mosquées et encore plus
quand c'est issu d'un mouvement qui n'a
pas adhéré au charte des valeurs
républicaines
je le dis avec gravité je pense que
autant et vous le savez je ne suis pas
pour la stigmatisation de la communauté
musulmane et je pense même qu'un élu de
la république
il peut aller à la rencontre de
représentants des mosquées comme on le
fait pour des représentants de l'église
catholique ou des synagogues ou autres
etc
mais je le dis aussi très clairement on
ne peut pas financer de manière publique
une mosquée et et surtout avec une
fédération qui n'a pas à respecter les
chartes de la valeur applique donc oui
le mit l'intérieur a totalement raison
et là il n'ya pas deux en même temps
possible et je trouve d'ailleurs c'est
pas la première fois que les verts sont
pris en flagrant délit par rapport à ces
questions là voilà on peut pas dire
matin midi et soir qu' on lutte contre
l'islamisme radical
on lutte contre un certain nombre de
dérives et l'a accompagnée comme ça ce
financement là donc moi je soutiens
pleinement ce qu'il faut pas pousser la
logique jusqu'au bout ou si on vous suit
et que la fédération dont il est
question me ligue au russe un je crois
qu'ils aient leurs pauvres représentant
plutôt de la communauté turque et
musulmane
si on considère qu'elle ait fait partie
de l'islam radical pourquoi pas demander
sa dissolution
non mais midi chorus c'est effectivement
une inspiration essentiellement la
communauté musulmane turque
nous en avons aussi dans mais aussi dans
mon territoire
la vérité aussi c'est que il faut
pouvoir en tout cas pas de financements
publics
ça c'est une priorité absolue est
ensuite hissé du contrôle au cas par cas
parce que vous avez différentes
associations différents lieux de
mosquées ou de regroupement ou autre
vous en avez qui respectent déjà la
république il y en a qui le font qu'ils
le respectent d'autres qui le font pas
et donc à chaque fois que ce n'est pas
le cas il faut pouvoir j'espère en tout
cas que la loi que nous qui a été
présenté au parlement sur la lutte
contre le séparatisme nous donnera les
moyens de ses suspensions
administratives mais je vais aller plus
loin le problème aujourd'hui c'est pas
simplement les mosquées parce que la
réalité c'est quoi même si vous
suspendez immense et qu'est-ce qui se
passe et bien en fait on crée des
associations est aujourd'hui la
difficulté que l'on a pour les pouvoirs
publics
c'est que beaucoup créé une association
dans un local à titre associatif et que
c'est là où ils font par exemple des
écoles coraniques moi je suis totalement
opposé à ce que sur notre territoire la
république on est des écoles coraniques
l'autre actualité c'est lui n'est fait
cette polémique sur les réunions non
mixte organisé par ce syndicat étudiant
lors une grande partie des républicains
demandent la dissolution de l'unef est
ce que vous allez proposer des
évolutions législatives sur ce sujet
alors d'abord de choses sur la
dissolution de l'unef on a posé hier une
question avec eric ciotti je pense que
c'est bien la moindre des choses
continuent de ce qui s'est passé c'est
inadmissible intolérable et ça doit être
s'en soucier
sanctionnée avec la plus grande force le
racisme anti blanc n'a pas sa place
comme d'ailleurs toutes les formes de
racisme en france il faut être aussi
sévère avec les uns qu'avec les autres
il n'y a pas
racisme à la découpe et donc là c'est
très clairement il faut une sanction
exemplaire et j'ai été frappé et même
choqués par les mots de madame vidal qui
s'est exprimé hier à l'assemblée
nationale est dans une espèce de
complaisance malsaine la réalité ensuite
c'est quoi c'est que nous nous demandons
une demandons depuis le début avec
julien aubert l'émission des formations
sur l'islam au gauchisme nous avons
demandé au mois de novembre
j'entends aujourd'hui que le
gouvernement nous dit mais oui c'est
très bien enfin moi j'ai eu trois refus
à l'assemblée nationale le président de
l'assemblée nationale a refusé notre
mission d'information le président de la
commission des affaires culturelles a
refusé une ambition d'information et la
présidente de la commission des lois la
refuser également donc là encore il ya
un gouffre entre les paroles de
condamnation que je salue de monsieur
bancaire et la reine et les actes
concrets qui fait que quand on demande
une mission d'information à l'assemblée
nationale on nous la refuse pas une fois
on ne la refuse trois fois sur un sujet
central
il ya une tribune juste pour finir ce
sujet une tribune signée de nombreuses
personnalités dont jean luc mélenchon
dont benoît hamon qui dénonce les appels
à dissoudre l'unef et qui condamne les
propos de jean michel blanquer rôle
rappelle jean michel blanquer
lui il disait que c'est pratique ça
ressemblait à du fascisme qu'est ce que
vous avez pensé de cette tribune et
cette tribune c'est la complaisance
malsaine que j'ai dénoncé tout à l'heure
et je pense qu'il faudra sur ces sujets
là avant une clarification absolu de la
mare de qui on aura au moment du débat
présidentiel je pense que jean luc
mélenchon est l'un des candidats à cette
élection présidentielle et que ce moment
là ça sera un moment de clarté politique
sur ces sujets là on n'a plus le droit
de reculer
on n'a plus le droit de tromper les
français on n'a plus le droit d'être
dans un entre deux on n'a plus le droit
d'être dans un en même temps coupable là
cela pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui la
situation est trop grave
toujours pareil sans stigmatisation mais
par contre avec la plus grande des
fermetés et quand on ne constate dans
son université pas partout non plus et
ne jetons pas non plus l'opprobre sur
l'ensemble comme je l'aï dit tout à
l'heure ça comité musulmane sur
l'ensemble la communauté éducative parce
que ça c'est faux et il ya aussi dans
l'université des gens extrêmement bien
et heureusement mais la liberté
académique
ce n'est pas la liberté de porter les
valeurs et les étendards de l'islamo
gauchisme matin médiation autre sujet
c'est celui de la fin de vie qui risque
d'opposer les les troupes
des républicains le député liberté et
territoires à olivier falorni défendra
le 8 avril une proposition de loi
donnant le droit à une fin de vie libre
été choisi alors clairement ça divise à
la fois la majorité ça divise à peu près
tous les groupes ou est-ce que vous vous
situez vous la vérité c'est que ces
trans courants et ça dépasse tous les
clivages et dans tous les groupes
politiques de l'assemblée nationale vous
aurez des votes différents
nous on laisse la liberté de vote parce
que tous les sujets qui porte à la
liberté de conscience fait qu'on a la
liberté de vote derrière donc comme tous
les groupes politiques
il y aura des divergences entre nous
avec quand même socle commun est le
socle commun c'est quoi c'est de
renforcer les soins palliatifs en france
je pense que là dessus on a une
convergence de vue de l'ensemble nos
députés
il faut des mesures nouvelles d'ailleurs
la semaine prochaine nous recevrons au
groupe parlementaire jean leonetti qui a
été la dernière grande loi bioéthique
c'est la loi leonetti je pense que c'est
une sommité pour nous et donc on aura un
débat à un échange avec lui pourquoi
justement ils puissent nous éclairer et
que chacun puisse prendre s'il y redire
sur la bad est ce que vous estimez
nécessaire d'aller au delà de cette loi
laisse limonetik j'ai aujourd'hui je
n'ai pas la réponse parce que j'ai
besoin de comprendre
j'ai besoin de savoir jusqu'au où on
veut aller ce que je dis simplement
c'est que je suis pas fermé par principe
et je suis pas hostile par principe
ce sont des sujets difficiles qui je
pense mérite simplement sur la forme
mieux qu'une proposition de loi des
scuds discuter en trois ou quatre heures
j'ai souvenir de la loi léonetti où il y
avait un vrai travail en amont est donc
moi ce que je veux si on veut poser le
débat dans la société française qui
attend débat extrêmement important et
qui touche beaucoup de familles de
france
moi je suis pas voir l'as comporte ce
débat là et qu'on l'ait dans la cité
française mais par un débat en catimini
entre soi en trois heures dans
l'hémicycle l'assemblée nationale
uniquement pour faire du buzz
donc c'est à dire vous demander au
gouvernement un vrai projet de loi sur
ce sujet non je demande au cours des 20
ou de maintenant au moins qu'on puisse
organiser le dire comme on a fait pour
les lois bioéthiques avec la loi classe
youn et y il y avait eu droit un an de
discussions d'échangés de débats je
pense d'ailleurs ce sera un sujet
certainement qui arrivera dans les
prochains mois et peut-être aussi dans
la campagne présidentielle
mais je crois pas que sur ce genre de
sujets là voyez on puisse légiférer
comme ça sur un coin de table
en quelques minutes et en présence est
jugée plus grave et en plus en pleine
pandémie
vraiment c'est pas la priorité des
français voilà et je trouve que c'est
pas le bon véhicule législatif c'est pas
le bon moment et surtout ça va créer du
malaise du traumatisme et ça va encore
plus fracturées la société française
mais par contre après sur le fond il ya
un débat qui mérite d'avoir lieu on va
parler des régionales le gouvernement
alors il dit que la question du report
des régionales n'est pas sur la table
que comme prévu il ya une clause de
revoyure le 1er avril mais que pour le
moment il n'est pas question de report
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas en train de
leur prêter une attention qui n'ont pas
finalement non mais moi je préférais du
tout très bien je prends acte avec vous
des déclarations de monsieur guérini je
prends acte des déclarations de monsieur
attal du premier ministre donc les
élections auront lieu
et comme dans tous les pays européens et
d'ailleurs si je chatte j'en entendu
hier les déclarations de près la
république qui nous a dit qu'il allait
tenir ses engagements si on a 30
millions de personnes vaccinées au mois
de juin je pense qu'on peut quand même
organiser les élections
si on a autant de personnes vaccinées il
ya plus de sujets voilà donc ce dont ils
s'opposeraient à tout report quelques
semaines la situation aujourd'hui c'est
pas une question de si c'est pas une
question quelle que soit la situation
sanitaire
d'abord ce que je demande c'est quoi
c'est que la situation sanitaire de mars
ne sont pas celles de juin enfin j'ose
espérer parce que sinon ça veut dire
qu'on n'a pas bougé sur l'acquis nation
en ce moment là ok mais il faudra
clairement comprendre pourquoi
mais si on nous dit et on tient cette
perspective là de vaccination ça veut
dire qu'à 30 millions de français vous
avez un français sur deux qui est
vacciné et ça veut dire que dans votre
potentiel électoral vous avez quand même
beaucoup de monde sont vaccinés donc il
ya plus de débat
alors après sur la campagne électorale
donc sur les opérations de vote pour moi
faire des opérations a rejoint à quoi va
ressembler cette fois-là parachute c'est
la question de la campagne sera question
de la campagne là aussi alors on peut
faire du télétravail
on peut s'adapter dans tous les modes de
vie le seul moment on pourrait pas
s'adapter ce serait sur les élections et
la vie démocratique
moi je retiens ce que prétend république
a dit il a dit il faut apprendre à vivre
avec le virus et il a raison mais il
faut apprendre aussi la démocratie à
faire vu la démocratie avec le virus
donc très concrètement vous pouvez
distribuer des tracts sur les marchés
c'est déjà le cas vous pouvez distribuer
dans les boîtes aux lettres
vous pouvez faire des réunions par
visioconférence
vous pouvez aller visiter des
entreprises vous pouvez rencontrer
dehors
des agriculteurs ou autres etc vous
pouvez accéder à la presse régionale
quotidienne qui est très importante
vous pouvez accéder à un certain nombre
de démissions voilà donc il est où le
problème
donc voilà je pense qu'il ya d'autres
problèmes bien sûr la bad que s'il ya
peu de participation
ça risque d'être bénéfique pour les
sortants et a priori donc pour vos
présidents de région mais vous savez je
suis pas sûr enfin oui une prime aux
sortants toujours mais il faut quand
même franchement une bonne dose il
fallait les calculs politiciens la
vérité aussi c'est qu'on peut estimer
qu'une une participation faible favorise
aussi les extrêmes et notamment le
rassemblement national
donc vous savez il faut quand même bien
mettre tout seul un valence dont je dis
simplement que aujourd'hui ça serait
quand même très singulier très
particulier et surprenant que la france
soit le seul pays d'europe à ne pas être
en capacité d'organiser des élections
et merci beaucoup merci d'amener un vote
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin merci
julien la une de la voix du nord c'est
évidemment la visite d' emmanuel macron
hier à valenciennes et la promesse de
vaccins et d'une course de vitesse mais
voilà c'est à lire dans la voix du nord
merci messieurs on passe au gîte au club
des terres et à la mutuelle nationale
territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics d'eau
vous présente le club des territoires
angie acteurs engagés dans la transition
zéro carbone des régions vous présente
le club des territoires
[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous présente le
club des territoires et avec une
aujourd'hui dans ce club détail et or
jean baptiste forêt et aurélien il ya
s'il nous rejoindre bonjour messieurs on
va parler avec vous beaucoup de
collectivités aujourd'hui on va d'avoir
parlé de l'impact de la crise sanitaire
sur les finances locales de nos
collectivités puis on va parler de la
relance dans les territoires quel rôle
pour les préfets dans cette relance est
l'objet d'un débat qui aura lieu au
sénat cet après midi on va reparler des
fameux sous préfet à la relance vous
allez voir on suivra l'actualité dans
nos régions on ira en occitanie aussi
l'année où la situation sanitaire se
dégrade fortement et brutalement c'est
ce que
[Musique]